Okay, so what happens in part two? We just need to copy paste all the commands from here
We just need to update all the packages of this OS. So look at this is when
That Mac OS notify you that you need to install some updates or Windows for example
Let's just copy paste all these commands from here. It will take some time, but it will not be long
Okay, I'll take a pause when it's done
Okay, next command is
Okay, we can type clear it will clear our terminal and then we need to
Let's create the director make dear and let's name it. I don't know
Okay, and we can put the LS
This is mean least command and we can see that hey this folder is created
it's very the same as when you create the folder on your Mac or in the windows and we can type CD and
Type the name of this folder. So basically we go inside this folder. We just dive into it
Yeah, we can see that we inside this folder now. We need to git clone our
repository
Git clone
Okay, it's done. So what happened here? We cloned
entire repository and
If we put the LS least command, we can see that here is the beat bridge
Beat bridge folder. Let's go into it
Okay. So as you can see here on the path
We're inside beat bridge folder and if we type down one more time LS mean least
We can see that there is the entire structure of our project. Let me show you so as you can see
The directories here beat the beat bridge contribute docs minor model neurons scripts and
Everything is here. This is cool, right?
Okay
What our next step we need to create the virtual environment. We're inside our beat bridge folder and
Let's create and when you can see a vent like this then it means that you created you activated your virtual environment
Let's install all necessary dependencies using this command. It will take some time. So I'll take a break here
And I will come back when it's done
Yep, it's done. We can see that everything installed and we can verify using this command. Let's check it out. It is a live version
Yeah, the latest version
Let's check
Yeah, be tense 4k, this is great news, okay
I'll take a pause here and then the next video will create the wallets and filled up with tokens